en frentes de guerra de trump son varios
porque va este que nos ha llamado la
atención ahora mismo a las noticias
porque se está disputando por parte de
él es un proyecto civil lo que aparenta
hacer una acción criminal que pretende
llevar el departamento de justicia y las
discusiones si estuvo bien o no su
allanamiento hay que poner esto en
contexto eeuu no está acostumbrado a que
sus primeros mandatarios sean encausados
criminalmente esto tal vez en
latinoamérica pasa con alguna frecuencia
en eeuu no habría que remontarse a nixon
que no hubo un proceso criminal pero
renunció ante la inminente
posibilidades que sucedieron aquí hay un
estado georgia está planteando y sus
criminales nueva york está haciendo
investigaciones el principal oficial de
financiero de las empresas trump se
declaró culpable hace una semana por lo
tanto son muchos los frentes pero hay un
frente más amplio que el político y ahí
es donde yo creo que esto es importante
porque hay unas elecciones de medio
término ahora en noviembre ahora los
republicanos han comparado el caso de
trump con el de los correos de hillary
clinton que recordemos uso su servidor
privado para manejar información de
estado y cuestionan que con ella no
ocurre absolutamente nada pueden
realmente compararse a estos dos casos
no no no no se pueden comparar porque lo
que pasa es que trump literalmente se
llevó documentos que claro todavía no
estamos 100% claro cuán
complicada es la situación pero son de
secretos o son secretos de estado y él
se lo llevó su defensa en ese sentido ha
sido con una medida de locura porque él
dice que como era el presidente él
decidía que era creo que no era pero si
no funciona el sistema el caso de
hillary y ya lo que uso es un correo
electrónico no autorizado pero nunca
sustrajo documentos y peor aún patrón se
les está acusando de obstruir la
investigación
en curso porque negó haber tener los
documentos o alegó haberlos entregados
todo así que yo creo que es claramente
distinguible las dos situaciones pero
depende de efectivamente se podrá
convencer la ciudadanía de que eran
documentos verdaderamente secretos ese
es el reto que tiene el los demócratas y
la administración bueno usted lo
mencionaba hace un momento es un caso de
una gran magnitud que no tiene
precedentes en el departamento de
justicia a que se atiene esta cartera al
investigar a un ex presidente como don a
otro
bueno el punto de vista político si gana
donald trump la processó llegamos hasta
las próximas elecciones y prevalece
donald trump tendrán la furia de un
presidente investigado así que se le
puede ir aquí la vida no digo
literalmente por la vida profesional a
mucha gente y tienen que asegurarse de
presentar un caso sólido para que
políticamente se mantenga